Good evening. I am Donna Lemon, and you're watching PEW news the most trusted news source on the internet I
I don't have the mark, I don't have the chair, I don't have the green screen. The first news, I mean, pewpeewp
the first news comes from Johnny D
*snoop dog plays and he sings along*
Johnny D which I made a video on a few months ago and..
he is now suffering from penumonia. I don't really know how it's pronounced pneumoniae. It's a lung bacteria
I think. I shouldn't even talk about it cause I don't know what it is, but it's bad, okay
It's bad, and he needs our help. I tweeted about this and Johnny D's wife made a video explaining the situation
Good evening, everybody. My name is Helen. I am Johnny D's wife
We have been married for almost 11 years
She talks about how Johnny D started the channel from her gifting
him the karaoke set that included all the songs, talks about how my video really helped out his channel a lot
and he was very happy about that, but as you probably know he got scammed.
Twice. And he never got any of that money
which sucks. I feel bad for for Johnny and his situation and of course
I want to help as much as I can. A lot of people said this was fake, so they uploaded another video
where you can clearly see Johnny is in critical condition
hello fans,
uh, thanks. You can pay for my wife's daughter for me being alive today. I passed out at home
I couldn't even get to my cell phone call, 911
She heard me screaming, woke up in the middle of the night and save my- saved me
I tweeted the GoFundMe page that they linked to which is helping covering the the cost for the medical bills
I want to be able to help as much as I can obviously. I want to be cautious about this
situation. A lot of people were criticizing me for not sharing this more and stuff like that
I just don't want the money to end up in the wrong persons hands since that technically has happened twice already
It is a lot of money we're talking about here. It's already five thousand dollars being donated, and you should definitely help
I want people to help
But I also want to be cautious and make sure that at least this amount of money gets to Johnny D
Make sure it does get covered by his bills before applying more
And then risking the chance and me giving this a shout out and that it will get lost again
That would just be the worst thing that could happen and I want to try to be
Somewhat responsible and hope for that not to happen and I want Johnny D to recover as best as possible
that's that's that's what I want more than anything
But just want to be a bit cautious before sending more people into help. Nevertheless
I hope Johnny recovers as soon as possible so we can have him back making his amazing karaoke videos
That's all we want. Johnny D, If you're watching keep hanging in there. The bros got your back boy.
I am Don Lemon and
I'm not supposed to get my own personal feedback
criticism on the news
cha- pewnews
But this story just makes me angry. How can the media keep attacking PewDiePie?
He hasn't even done anything. What is up PewDiePie? The troubling content of YouTube's biggest star
Childish, offensive and immensely popular. The YouTube star whose real name is Felix Kjellberg
Continues to command a huge audience. But what is he really saying nah?
That's not the, that's not the tagline I remember reading. Here's what the original headline said, childish
bigoted and immensely popular. The YouTube star- whAt? You changed it. You changed the tag
It's like, can we call him a bigot?
Let's just not do that. Maybe we shouldn't call him bigoted because then that it seems like we're just a bunch of kids throwing words
And names around. This article to summarize it sort of insinuates that me creating a book club is somehow a bad
That people should pay more attention to what I'm doing online because who knows what he's gonna do next next month
He might tell them to read Mein Kampf
A lot of people on Twitter were really mad about this article, and I appreciate people standing up for me, but personally
I'm not mad. I'm also not ignoring the fact that they they did say some nice things in the article for example here
They say that Felix is funny
intelligent and
innovative and highly charismatic which of course all of this I am. he is. but also being called a narcissist, a bigot and
Potential alt-right. I I'm not mad okay. I know it might be confusing for some people. I never technically
labeled myself towards any political
What's it called? the group or opinion
I just personally don't see myself aligning perfectly with anyone or anything and really at the end of it I don't care
I genuinely just don't care. I talk a lot about social politics on this channel
I criticize it and I make fun of it a lot because
My channel was attacked by it
I don't see this article as an attack on me despite a lot of people
Thinking that it is and getting a lot of people angry. I see it as a display of fear
I wasn't necessarily upset about it and also I'm kind of used to this sort of treatment by now
I think they know that I have influence, they know it might not be over their generation
But it is influence that is stronger than theirs at least of the next, and I think there's a there's a definite fear there
But they're losing control. I feel like there's a bigger picture to discuss here where
The media has created a landscape of social politics where they've gone around throwing labels at everything
racist, bigot
sexist, alt-right like it's nothing because it's quick, it's effective and it's powerful and it's a great way to control people
He may not have called me alt-right in the article
But so desperately wanting to call me alt-right. To call him an alt-right
agitator would perhaps be unfair as he has never publicly
Identified with a proto fascist movement, but he shares much of their culture and amplifies
It across the world. Just because other people don't share the exact same
opinions as the media does not mean that everyone else is an alt-right. This landscape of
Constantly throwing around labels and twisting the meaning of them and changing to fit into this
Obscure shape, it's just nonsensical. It's laughable
Which is why I enjoy criticizing it on this channel, and which is why I enjoy humoring it because it's just so bizarre
Oh, what was said was a joke? Doesn't matter, we can call him this
Oh, what was said was taken out of context? Doesn't matter
We can call him this. Does that mean I completely agree with political groups that are popular online
For not agreeing with this idea? No. Come on media. I don't want to keep fighting with you
Why what do I gotta do? If you actually watch my videos I think you'd find that it's not that bad alright
We're just reading books here alright. And reading books is a good thing. Huh don't be so bigoted.
Brad is now going to say the weather. Brad, tell us about the weather. Smug.
I say the weather sounds pretty smug right now
I forgot the most important news. ASS is coming out on all consoles.That's right. Nintendo Gameboy,
Nintendo Advanced and the Xbox Switch
Check it out guys. ASS full version
You definitely don't want to miss this. For more info link in the description Have I told you by my chair
Let's just get this last story
out of the way I
I almost don't want to talk about it, but at the same time, then it might seem like I don't care or that
I don't think it's important. As you probably heard there was a shooter at the YouTube headquarter in San Bruno
A shooter entered with a handgun and shot three people and
Then itself and thank God no one got killed except the shooter of course at least that's what I know.
I'm not sure what is the situation of the victims so far or the ones that got hurt
I don't want this to be another video where someone talks about the situation
But nothing really gets said. I've seen so many of those
I know people mean well, and I know it's hard to discuss these situations
But I think it would be ignorant of me to ignore the fact that I think it would be ignorant or or cowardice
For me to ignore the fact that
the the shooter did acknowledge that
The shooter did speak about demonetization and that frustration
And it hasn't been confirmed if that was the reason behind the shooting, but it's it's out there
I saw on the website of the shooter there was
promoting some videos of demonetization rants
and saying that
Their videos were being censored or
Less views or something like that and thank God
None of my videos were there Jesus Christ
YouTube's had a rough year, man. I
For anyone that was involved in this horrible incident, I'm just so sorry
You had to go through something like this
I can only imag- I can't imagine what that's like and to everyone that works at YouTube
I I really sympathize for having to go to work and
With at least some bit of fear now. This is awful. The situation just to put it plain and simply
It's just bad for everyone, and I don't want it to seem like I'm pointing fingers. I don't think this whole
This situation is anyone's direct fault and whether it's YouTube or the community
But I think it's important to at least acknowledge the fact that there is a huge
Division between the creators and and the website and I think there's been a very frustrating year
For everyone involved where all the changes that came with the adpocalypse led to so much
Confusion and anger and I would never have guessed
it would have led to something so horrible and despicable like this, but a lot of time with the
These situations what I do is I just go on Twitter, when things go wrong with YouTube
I just go on Twitter because it's a good way to relieve stress
or I'll make some sort of YouTube rant and
Discuss it in a humorous way to sort of rant about it cause it it relieves that stress
and I I've talked about this before but I know from the outside it might be hard to understand because
YouTube comes with so many amazing perks it's really like made my life so much better than I could ever imagine
It's given me my dream job and all these things possible, but it is so mentally
toiling sometimes I sort of forced myself over the years to distance myself from YouTube because it's it's just too stressful
otherwise and
I've talked to a lot of different creators over the years, and I think most of them admits to at least some point
to have gone through a really tough mental period, it's not always
As simple as it may seem
And I I really think most people on YouTube has gone through that at some point
whether they care to admit it or not and
I can only imagine that if you have that stress and anger built up over a long time
And you're a fucking crazy person then that's what creates these sort of
insane scenarios and
Obviously, I don't know if that's necessarily what happened, but I'm just speculating here, but if that is the case
I think it's really important that
More than ever that we really connect
YouTube and the creators more than we have. I think YouTube is definitely working on that and
Should just keep doing that and but I also think we as creators can do a better job at communicating
with YouTube as well and not always just
rant and talk about it in a
Stupid way like I've been doing for example a lot of times
I have been trying to engage more with YouTube in a more serious way to actually fix a lot of the issues
Because we have we it's it's a it's a crisis situation
And and I think this shows that. I don't want to see them all like kumbaya, we should all just get together and hold hands
Kind of moments. But I do think at times like this, It's just more important than ever just to come together. That's it
That's all I have to say about it
It just sucks. I don't know what else to say.
Thanks for watching PEW news. I am Don Lemon. It's been my pleasure
Hopefully next week won't be so
Horrible
This video will definitely have garbage ads on it
So I do appreciate if you want to support the show by buying a PEW news mug, link is in the description
Have a great one, and I'll see you next time. I am Don Lemon, everybody
I'm not editing anything in here. Just leave.